this program is brought to you by Emory
University
everything humans know of our planet we
were told had been shared
you lied to us
made a grave mistake
Isaac Asimov created the Three Laws of
Robotics that is he suggested in one of
his science fiction works but it then
spread that a robot needs to be
inculcated with three ideas one is I
will never let a human come to harm I
will never harm a human and that I will
protect myself except insofar as it
violates one of the first two so a robot
can't protect itself at the expense of a
human life for human harm so what you
have often when you have science fiction
stories or movies about robots gone bad
is how did they go around some of these
protections that we assume will build
into robots when we create them because
what we don't want is robots going
around killing human beings now there
are two interesting ways to get around
that one is to what about robot soldiers
right so robot soldiers have to protect
you but kill the enemy so there have
been some science-fiction that have
tried to use that vehicle but what
transformers does is it bill is it takes
another attack which is what about alien
robots alien robots aren't necessarily
designed by us to protect us so they get
the opportunity to create good robots
and bad robots I think that this does
tap into a very deep fear we have of our
creations not being willing to protect
us and I think it is it is a direct line
back to even Frankenstein and the idea
of creating even an organic form that
goes out of control and it's the idea
that we are creatures that are
characterized by our creating things we
are tool-making creatures we are
surrounded at all times by the things we
create right now sitting in this room
there isn't a single thing we can look
at we can see that wasn't created by
human beings and so we always worry that
the products of our hands will somehow
harm us hurt us whether we're talking
about global warming or whether we're
talking about robotics and so what
transformers does is it plays on that
fear that these created creatures
are going to come back to haunt us are
going to come back to hurt us now these
happen to be aliens but it still plays
to that idea that that human beings at
least have a conscience or a soul or
whatever we want to talk about that we
can appeal to or try to get access to to
try to stop them from doing the wrong
thing but a robot or never sure when
artificial intelligence first got
underway in its early days it thought
that human mental processing was a very
was rational and that if it could mimic
it it could then create artificial
intelligence that was similar to human
intelligence and what it underestimated
at the beginning was the powerful part
that our emotional lives and brains play
and in the way in which we think about
the world and even in the way in which
we make decisions and so now you get to
the question of how do we create robots
that will somehow think like human
beings and not by the way like computers
because we already have computers to
think like computers and maybe we can
already create some primitive robots
that think like computers but as we all
know computers do not think like human
beings and so they may be very good at
playing chess but they actually play
chess very differently than we play
chess they just can quickly calculate
millions and millions of moves while we
use something we call intuition or or
sort of a gestalt view of what's going
on to not have to go through all the
moves that the great chess master knows
won't get them anywhere right so they
can look at a finite number of moves
whether we will ever be able to create
artificial life that can combine that
emotional piece is is really an
interesting question and one that nobody
knows the answer to
we don't understand how emotions work in
the brain we don't understand how the
limbic system works which is the seed of
the emotions we don't even understand
how the limbic system really interacts
with the
prefrontal cortex and other places in
the brain we're more rational thought is
process so we certainly can't begin to
create that in robots at least until we
understand it in ourselves
you
the preceding program is
Marie University